good morning and welcome to this um
cabinet for the Monday the 6th of
November can we have apologies for
absence do we have any absence apologies
from Council of
rock and disclosures of Interest oh by
the way on the C for councelor Rock can
we all send our um good wishes for his
uh getting well and um hope hope Natalie
counselor Gest is the one that's in
contact with him the most please send
our wishes to him
officially thank you disclosures of
Interest any disclosures of Interest no
minutes do we have um a confirmation and
of the minutes do we accept the minutes
that I can sign them that there a true
record are you agreed everybody agreed
okay thank you very much
indeed next item
is
um just make sure that I've got the
right page is matters matters to be
referred to council nonone matters for
decision by the cabinet uh the first one
is one that comes under my strategic
leadership portfolio which is about the
climate change Reserve eligibility and
financial approval procedure
uh and that's on pages 11 to
12 and the recommendation here is that
the climate change Reserve eligibility
and financial approval procedure set out
in the report is agreed and that we have
a statford on aen community climate
change fund of 100,000 to be established
and this will be released in two
tranches funded from the climate change
Reserve bids will be invited for
allocation by the end of March 2024 and
will be appraised using the process set
out in the report there is a
considerable amount of uh detail there
about how the the appraisals will be
carried out and uh if you could um let
me know if if the you've got any issues
that you want to raise um otherwise it
will be uh the summary will be the
recommendation as approved anybody got
any questions that they want to raise on
the climate change the community clim CL
change and the climate change
Reserve uh councelor for passingham uh
you said £100,000 it doesn't mention 100
it only mentions the 50,000 first tranch
in this report it is to be 50,000 in two
trenches of two trenches of 50,000 which
will be the 100,000 uh and it's just to
make sure that we're getting the
procedures right um and making sure that
we've checked the the the processes uh
and then the the second tranch will be
released it depends on the on the uh
amount of um you know interest that
there is in it as well yeah uh councelor
Crump thank you councelor junet and
again I'll Endor the the best wishes to
councelor rock who are our share County
Award with at lton yeah we we discussed
this briefly um at see on Friday um and
we we welcome the money but whether
there could be any links with a green
shoots food green shoots food fund sorry
got these teeth just testing them I
think that the green shoots fund at the
county where there can be some
interlinking uh and and pointing back
and forward to one another and making
sure people can get the most for their
uh um project as well so the the
combination of the two and whether one
can be used to leave the money in from
another fund as well so if that just my
clear I certainly think it's worth
always giving information about all the
sources of funding that um the
communities can access uh for you know
to address climate change I gave a very
good um it was an interesting invitation
that I had to give a talk in on on
Saturday um to the churches together
about uh climate change and um one of
the things that I I am very um keen on
is to make sure that people are part of
this process that they understand and
our um know what they can do and how
they can do it and be included and be
given the information to do the right
thing and be helped and enabled um to
address climate change and it's not just
climate change it's about um green
spaces mental health and well-being but
that is for example if you um if you
make sure that somebody's house is well
insulated that's addressing climate
change but it's also making sure that
people are warm and cozy and their how
homes and also do not suffer ill health
as a result of damper mode so the this
it's climate change is is the is the
central thing but it's actually affects
a lot of people's lives that's why we
need people to have the information and
be directed to other funds if this one
does not suit their needs or if they can
be find other sums that would actually
help with this uh bid with their bid on
this particular particular subject there
is also in there um council cter do you
want to bring come in
I just wanted to say um chair that we
are very keen to um get this money
moving um this money's sat in reserve
for a long time um and we actually want
to make some practical use of it and we
hope that um communities will come
forward with really good schemes and
should they be more than £100,000 I'm
sure we can find more money from that
Reserve to to do to do that in due
course but uh I think the important
message to get out is this is money
available we want really good schemes to
come come forward where we could spend
it and it is also in um key to note that
the this report also covers the spending
of um climate change fund on the C
council's own property for example to
decarbonize and make sure that they are
their own footprint is kept as low as
possible as well so that we are setting
the example for others to
follow so that is part and parcel of the
whole report so if we go back to the
recommendations if nobody else has got
any other comments the recommendations
are that we um the financial approve
approval procedure set out in in the
report is agreed that a straford onen
community climate change fund of 100,000
is established to be released in two
tranches that will be a 50,000 each
funded from the climate change Reserve
bids to be invited for allocation by the
end of March 2024 and appraised using
the process set set out in the report
report could I have somebody um that
will um second that I will propose that
if anybody else counselor calls and do
does the cabinet agree okay all agreed
thank you very much indeed that's really
really
appreciated moving on we've got the
treasury management strategy midyear
review 2023 to2 24 which is on pages 21
to
38 councel Curtis
thank you leader um this is fairly
factual um summary is to provide members
with an annual treasury management
review of the activities for
2223 and I'd like to thank first of all
Katie Sylvester for this comprehensive
report the
appendices
um just a a couple of comments really on
page
22 um just like to draw the cabinet's
attention to um now where is it sorry I
can't find it um 6.1 um we employ the
service of the link group who advis on
Treasury management and investment
matters issuing interest rate forecasts
and Advising on Treasury management
practices and so forth um on page 28
just a couple of comments I think
Council cabinet may like to note um on
page 28
2.5 um the delegation by the Council of
the role of scrutiny of Treasury
management strategy and policies is to a
specific named body and for this Council
the delegated body is the overview and
scrutiny committees I just thought i' um
I'm sure we've all read this very
thoroughly but I think that's worth just
worth noting and this afternoon we also
have a cash management working group
meeting which will include an update
from link and abedine which will inform
the budget
process um so I would recommend the
cabinet to agree the recommendation to
note the treasury management activities
to date in 2223 20 2023 24 detailed in
appendix one and to note the potential
indicators detailed in appendix one and
the compliance with all indicators thank
you leader so if you are um proposing
that one um I would is there anybody
that will second it to council calls and
are we all in agreement thank you very
much and that's so noted and all agreed
thank you next item is the capital
budget monitoring period for 1 to6 2023
24 on pages 39 to 54 and again this is
councelor Curtis thank you leader um I'd
like to thank Nichol Reynolds for
preparing the report and the appendices
it gives cabinet details of the capital
budget monitoring for the period 1 to
six so that's first of April this year
to the 30th of
September um I'm just going to pick up
one item that was raised
uh a few days ago um and this is on
slippage um.
one3 uh slippage of
22231 million 11,1
73,74
there is a full breakdown of that given
in the summary given in summary on in
appendix one on page one and the
following Pages give full details of all
the slippage items so all the detail of
that slippage is contained in these
appendices so I just thought I'd mention
that as it was raised by um somebody
earlier
on um so report comes with the
recommendations that the position on
capital expenditure and income for
period 1 to six of 23 24 is received any
issues identified for further
consideration to be addressed by refer
the report to the cabinet and to the
portfolio holder so I'd like to propose
that thank you thank you deer do we have
any comments to be made on that one if
there are no comments do we have
somebody that's willing to second
that Council
calls okay thank you
Council if there's no other comments are
we all agreed on that one agreed agreed
all right agre right thank you very much
indeed that's
agreed
the next item is again for councelor
Curtis and it's the revenue budget
monitoring period 1-6 2023 24 pages 55
to 68 councelor curses thank you leer
um so this is to update the cabinet on
the position of the council's revenue
expenditure and income as of period 6
30th of September together with an
estimated net outter position for each
service in
2324 and Jessica l hased prep this and
I'd like to thank all for that um just a
few comments if I may um on page
2.3 um as previously I I covered this in
the previous report in September the
section 151 officer Mr B assures me that
the housing benefit writeoffs are within
the expected parameters and are
primarily the result of personal
bankrupt
or moving on leaving no forwarding
address um if residents return efforts
are made to chase the outstanding debts
as required by our
constitution within this right off
section um members will note that there
are two additional lines reporting the
value and number of writeoffs in respect
of non-domestic rates that's business
rates and council
tax this is included for information
purposes and is required as part of the
council's Constitution previously this
has has been reported within a report
from revenues but our new monitoring
officer consided it better practice that
is now included as part of the regular
budget monitoring
report both these items relate to
collection fund that is a fund that is
separate to the council's revenue budget
where all receipts for council tax and
business rates are paid and any
writeoffs in respect of these will not
be directly funded by the council but in
proportions shown on the council tax
bill
and the receipts from the business rates
pooling
Arrangement um I'll just add to that
although these figures look substantial
and obviously they are with the domestic
rates and Mr Bell I'm sure correct me if
I get anything wrong at this point um
with the domestic rates we do achieve
99.6%
collection
and of this the um council tax sorry the
the council tax we achieved
99.6% collection and of that council tax
although it seems a substantial figure
only 7% of that would actually be
retained by the count by this Council um
and the overall sum collected for um
council tax and non-domestic rates um
is200 million so out of that 200 million
although these are substantial figures I
think we need to just bear in mind that
it is a very small percentage
thereof
um
313 um Building Services the uh
unfavorable variance here is due to
higher due to higher interest rates oh
sorry I've I've gone on um 313 um as
previously reported in September uh we
are appearing The increased business
rates for Elizabeth House
the new tency Arrangements entered into
by the previous administration have not
yet been finalized and kez had indicated
that they were going to take occupancy
earlier on in this year but that's now
being deferred so there is that loss in
rate in Revenue there um off street
parking has revenues have been affected
by poor weather at Key times if we get a
wet bank holiday it has a major impact
on parking revenues I think parking
revenues it's about3 million pounds
Richard
it is
yeah um page
314 favorable variance on due to higher
interest rates um obviously interest
rates have been considerably higher um
than
anticipated but again Mr B is cautioning
I think wisely against projecting this
increased income going forward at the
same rate given the volatility of
interest rates and volatility of the
interest of the international
situation um
the council tax
reduction Grant again I this was raised
in September I covered it then but this
was due to an unexpected and completely
unforeseen reduction in a grant from
central
government um moving on page
67 um the ear marked reserves as part of
the budget process we will be
undertaking a review of all the year
marked
reserves um just a few General comments
if I may before we come to the
recommendations we are all aware of the
increasing number of councils facing
severe financial difficulties and as we
all know several have issued section 114
notices since 20,000 since 2010 central
government funding to local authorities
has been cut by 50% so it's hardly
surprising that many councils find
themselves in this
position there isn't any room for
complacency but fortunately this council
is not in that
position but we do live in a very
volatile world next year we're going to
have a general election and future
funding levels are
uncertain we're now in the throws of the
budget setting process for
2425 and with continued shrinking of
central government support for local
government sector there will be some
difficult choices to be made
and this Administration will need to
balance the need for caution maintaining
sufficient reserves against future
uncertainty with ensuring that we spend
resources on good quality public
services that meet our residents needs
especially the most vulnerable in our
community and delivering delivering our
political priorities in January our
proposals will go to public
consultation and I very much hope that
while public consultation on budgets may
not set Hearts racing across the
district I hope that you know we really
can get the public to engage in that
exercise and we hear from Mo those most
directly affected and that can inform
our budget final decisions so thank you
for letting me make those points back to
the report and the recommendation before
cabinet is one that the actual net
variance at as at period six and the
estimated Revenue outter for 23 24 be
received any issues identified for
further consideration by a further
report to cabinet or to the portfolio
holder and two that the write offs
contained in paragraph 2.3 be noted
thank you
leader do I have any comments that
anybody wants to make councilor W
hoggins just a brief comment really that
the reason that we're in such a a a good
Financial State is for The Prudent way
in which uh the budget's been managed
during the uh time considerable time the
conservatives were in control of this
Council so I think that does need uh
mentioning and uh we await your budget
with interest thank
you councelor
Crum yeah just a brief question to um uh
councelor Curtis I I'll start with point
and move on um I think we need to Choose
Wisely how and where we consult um
because when I was was a local
government officer there was a phrase
consulted to get consulted to death and
people seem to
get consultation
fatigue so again we're Consulting on a
lot of things so let's make sure we
consult wisely um with and get the
messages out as simply as possible so I
think that's one key thing but my main
question is to do with investment
interest um that again when I worked in
local government sometimes this would be
classed as forist forist income um the
extra 150k from investment interest um
mainly due to higher interest rates that
we hadn't forecast and we discussed this
when we had the budget working group
before the task and finish group that
you were I on Council Cur so I know is
very difficult to do uh so we've got the
higher unexpected interest rates and
obviously the higher balances that we've
got because of the capital slippage if
we haven't spent the money it's still in
our accounts but we want to spend the
money so it'll go out of accounts and
therefore we'll have less money to
invest so they will get less interest so
that that's one position and also I
believe some of the balances are made up
of monies we have to pay back to the
government still good stuff yeah I like
all these NS so once that money is sent
back once we sent spent the capital
slippage and once the interest right
start to come down which they invariably
will this almost a million pounds worth
of additional income will would
disappear uh so therefore um if that
money wasn't there at the moment we
would be showing a near forecast
overspend of a million pounds uh based
on the reports you uh
48,000 over spend uh currently add on
the 950,000 additional income which you
gra so the
98,000 worth of income that yeah sorry
um a black hole in our account so it'd
be interesting to see how we're going to
take this into account in the future
when we have we haven't got this
guaranteed income in the
future councelor Curtis do you want to
come back on that one thank you D yes
I'll try to I'm not entirely sure what
the
question was there can I make it simple
then there's there's a potential black
hole in the accounts of almost a million
pounds if we weren't going to get the
level of in investment income because we
have less money to invest because we've
either spent it on Capital program or we
paid the government back the money we're
holding on
account thank you thank you leader um
first of all I think you're absolutely
right councelor Crum that we need to be
cautious and that's why in my reply or
in my comments I did say that we'd been
advised by Mr Burl that we should be
very very wary of um assuming anything
in terms of of the higher interest rates
but I'll I'll pass over to to Mr Burl
for further information thank
you yes thank you um yeah you're
absolutely right and that's why we're
doing a
comprehensive cash cash flow forecast
that goes into next year and that will
form part of the budget review process
that we're about to enter
into um you are right again that last
budget monitoring we did predict
a greater unfavorable variance but the
additional interest has seen us through
that prior to that I had made an ear Mar
reserve for inflation the effects of
inflation inflation's stuck around
longer and a higher
rate that means I don't have to draw on
that ear Mar Reserve this year so yes
it's seen us through this year and so
that's the sort of thing that we've got
to bear in this budget set in cycle and
get right hopefully or as good as we can
and uh thank you leader and um councelor
W hoggins thank you for your comments as
well and um I would just note that when
I presented my first report in July
cabinet may recall that the estimated
outter position then showed a deficit of
£480,000
whereas now the um outter position shows
a deficit reduced to 4 £
48,000 um I quite look forward to
councelor Harvey's next letter to the
statford herald noting that um rather
better position thank you councelor
Wallin I think councelor Curtis that
that's a little you on Rocky ground
there because as we all know that the
interest rates have been hiked to such a
position that we ended up in that
situation so so thanks awfully we could
bring up off street parking and the um
the unfavorable variance of 80,000
pounds and the uh bringing in the not
very popular parking permits but we'll
let that lie for the time being thank
you to we've got more to more figures
for that so thanks very much indeed but
uh we're watching you you're you are
watching us thank
you thank you should we um put your uh
item to the U
vote recommendations you propose them
anybody seconding those uh that the
proposals can
councelor councelor G is is seconding it
are we all agreed then on the report
thank you very much indeed
appreciated moving on to the next item
uh the slight alteration here it's it's
not the extension of contract it's UB
community Transport scheme future
options and that's on page 69 to 98 and
that's to consider the options providing
a similar provision of the ubis
community Transport Service operating in
the District following the the the um
the cessation of the existing contract
councelor calls would you like to
address this thank you leader yes uh the
recommendations we're bringing to uh
cabinet today um are in response to some
of the changes we're having to deal with
um I'll I'll go do the recommendations
first that we agree to work
collaboratively with warshire County
Council for the future procurement of a
demand responsive transport syst
solution and subject to that be uh
recommendation number one being agreed
that this procurement will seek to
incorporate enhancements in the
scheduled public transport
infrastructure in Stratford p aen and
that the option to bolt on additional
Services where utilization justifies
these being considered subject to the
budget setting process so essentially
what we're bringing to Cabinet today is
to get approval that we can uh on the
process to continue this service uh what
we're not looking to approve today is
what the final overall service will look
like because we will have to go through
the process with warshire County Council
and they unfortunately um are not ready
to have that process sorted and done by
the time we need it which is March 24 so
um what we're I'm asking you today is to
approve the process for working with the
County Council to get the the uh service
sort
Ed um we're all familiar with UB um
working with warshire County Council
means that anything we put in place is
economically much more sensible than
going it alone um and creating our own
service and we will essentially have
more service for the money that we're
putting into it and that they can
provide um we will have a selection of
additional bolt-on options pick and mix
once the um procurement process has
being gone through but this will allow
us to allow wara time to go through
their procurement and tendering
process um chief
executive thank you Ju Just just to
build upon the points that Council Co
are just introduced we we were notified
as an authority on Thursday last week
that the procurement exercise that is
planned to be undertaken by the County
Council won't be completed by the end of
March 2024 as we had anticipated
we are looking at a delay of a few
months we'll be bringing a report to the
next meeting of the cabinet to consider
the interim period between the current
cessation of the contracts on the 31st
of March 2024 and when that procurement
exercise will be completed by so there
will be a further report coming to the
cabinet in
December thank you very much for that
clarification uh Council will hins yeah
can I just ask for some clarity then
what will happen to the uh budgets that
the monies that that the County counc
expecting to receive from us given the
fact that there is this delay in
deciding with with the with the with the
procurement and also I'd like to
emphasize that I think it's really
important that as part of this exercise
and the the the new contract that we are
actually looking at the best value for
our residents and all of the residents
throughout statford district and with
particular emphasis on those in the
wildest um wildest most rural areas um
and that this
substantial amount of money that's been
specified here is is spent as wisely as
possible and Dare I ask are we going to
go to our Parish councils to ask what
they would like to see happen as well
thank
you I I can um yeah absolutely so the
report that will come in December will
consider the options and consider the
value and and if it's within the
existing budget framework fine if not
then we'll have to make a recommendation
to Council in December for potentially
some inter funding to keep the existing
Arrangements going until the new
Arrangements can be put in
place yeah it's it's disappointing that
you know the the procurement um by the
County Council does not is not aligned
with our uh original date they they um
have put it back by some
months one of the areas that receives
the greatest number of passengers using
UB buus is oler and I feel very very
strongly about protecting them that
service uh and when you look at the age
range of people uh I again I am very
very passionate about making sure that
that service continues uh so it's a
matter of negotiating with the County
Council to find out how much we can add
to the service and what options what
extra options we can we can gain um by
doing going through this process to make
sure that it is a as good a service and
a better service than it is even at the
moment
I think I just going to say that it
isn't a question of the the service I
think it's more a question of a service
needs to be retained for residents and I
think there is scope for all par for all
counselors to ask their Parish councils
um and town councils what they think is
is is needed because as I said um there
is some disparity of use and interaction
with the service thank you I'm quite
happy that coun that Parish councils be
be asked we have a a comp a complete
breakdown in the papers of the um age
distribution the number of passengers
the average age where they're coming
from there is actually a complete
section in appendix six uh three sorry
uh that looks at the number of bookings
after the school runs across every um
sort of area as well and uh uh appendix
for outlines those areas that that get
the greatest and the least uh use reg in
in as a as a region so they're a very
very useful set of data that we want to
build on thank you we've got a
recommendation and the recommendation is
that we work collaboratively with warer
County Council for the future
procurement of a demand responsive
transport solution and subject to that
recommendation one that this procurement
will seek to incorporate enhancements in
the schedule and I emphasize
enhancements in the scheduled public
transport infrastructure in statford
upon aen and that the option to bolon on
additional Services where utilization
justifies these to be considered subject
to the budget setting process so that is
the recommendation and then it will come
back uh once we hear from wari County
Council so we've had a proposal from
councilor Kohl's do we have a seconder
councelor Groot is seconding it are you
all happy to um to recom back that
recommendation all accepted thank
you the next item that was on the
original um agenda item nine is no
longer to be considered uh that is
coming back to the next um cabinet
meeting so we will move on to item 10
which is delivering local needs local
Choice rural
housing and this will become from um
councelor Council
course my apologies counc
CER and this is on page uh
137 uh and it is about the approach to
delivering homes for local people in
rural
areas so I think it's a very
straightforward report um and it's uh
something I would recommend that we
support I am heartened to to see that
the contract for the rural housing
enabler runs now to 31st of March 2026
because I value the the work that has
been done over a number of years in um
trying to look at housing needs surveys
and um making sure that uh local needs
uh are are are current are looked at in
a range of uh rural housing areas uh I
know um the officer concerned has been
working in my area uh on a couple of the
one doing housing needs surveys and
looking for potential uh sites and I I
know that she has done so over on many
many areas across the whole of the
district so the recommendation um
councelor couo you're proposing the
recommendation yes and that is that the
approach to delivering homes local
people in rural areas set out in this
report is endorsed have we got any
questions that anybody wants to
raise councilor W hoggins it's not a
question it's just a statement that we
I'm very impressed with the work of um
both officers here rata MOS and Sarah
Brook Taylor the the standard of work
they commit to doing is is exemplary and
um it is one of the greatest
um legacies I think of of any council is
this type of housing that is built and I
thank them on behalf of my residents for
the um hard and sometimes difficult work
that they that they um that they
undertake so this we fully endorse this
report thank
you thank you do we have a second that
will will um look at the recommendations
councilor grot is everybody else happy
with the report as written then we'll
accept it all agreed thank you
next item is part C issues arising from
overview and scrutiny committee were
there any
issues yeah just wanted to council junit
um a brief update and uh some just some
comments that hopefully will be taken
into account uh we spoke um about the
task and finish group uh to do with
housing
associations um and and that is likely
to be lead on to another task finish
group regarding antisocial Behavior
which is which is potentially linked uh
and we we need to make sure that all
Partners involved in antisocial Behavior
are you tackling it not the people are
actually doing it are um know what
they're doing their rights and
responsibilities and protocols and and
uh offices um at the meum had experience
in other authorities where this is more
prevalent and
we we think that's important and we
think without prejudging it we think
we're about to give information so this
could be tackled at a more strategic
level as well so I think that's going to
be helpful so very briefly on that the
other points we've got were to do what's
my computer works uh shakes England came
a very informative presentation from the
operations and Mark director positive
prospects for continuing coid recovery
our recovery in is has been a lot better
than the rest of the country um and uh
yeah it's it was very very impressive so
um it was it did all go well for the
future um and we asking quite a few
questions that were quite challenging
and we had some proper meaningful
answers as well I note on now the SE
report is has been pulled um we we did
discuss that in um great depth and
Council C to be fair we were pushing
against an Open Door when it concerned
about some possible improvements and I
think that's probably one of the reasons
why the report has been put back to the
December's meeting um some of the
questions were raised about scoring
process the risk of subjectivity
inconsistency and the lack of trans
potential lack of transparency in this s
bids we fa to um map of where the bids
were coming from would have been helpful
uh so we could potentially identify any
barriers to bidding while certain parts
potentially w't um wen't bid in for this
and we hope that the amended report
comes to um cabinet next month will take
into account as many possible
suggestions from osc as possible because
most of those and I think Council cach
will nod or shake his head if he
disagrees were felt to be fair and
reasonable um and again we as I see
we're going to consider this as a future
item in June uh next year but we may
need to um amend that in in light of the
delay of this um uh the report so that
was quite quite positive you know I
think it was right that the report
wasn't wasn't right so um let's get the
report right and make sure we're clear
and transparent as possible and we
talked about
um UB
um and again members highlighted that
evening late afternoon service was
important um we need to make sure our
trans it was looked at in relation to
the transposition in general and house
dis we can make it and again we need to
look at the current capacity and usage
level of
service uh and how we maximized
engagement on that so definitely very
good point there for consultation
against the Curtis
um and the we went into two halves it
was um a long meeting um and the second
half of the meeting was around the going
about the contion walk integrated care
board who we managed to get in um we had
some residents engagement who spoke
about their problems we had many
questions from members of the public and
counselors that we all to ask on their
behalf and to be fair to the
representatives from the ICP they did
really give an informative presentation
on the roles and responsibilities they
cleared a lot of the items up where
there was
ambiguity uh we did mainly concentrate
on the elen bodger
hospital and we actually got some
several points from this that uh there
was more clarity why the bed review
hadn't carried out by sft hadn't been
published because it's now forming part
of an overall one done by the
ICB and therefore it wouldn't been fair
to release this in isolation because
that ICB covers several different areas
as
well um we've got uh details and actions
that will form part of the minutes and
once they're agreed by ICB uh they will
be part of the public record so so that
was I think that is a real big win so we
we're sorting out a lack of consult out
consultation yeah um so now sorting out
we've got a clear record so everybody
knows what's happening and I think that
was lacking you know um for some reason
and the other thing as well is that the
over in scrutiny committee would make a
formal response to the consultation that
ICB are doing so we will make sure we
are representing everybody's views
about this so um a really good session
one of the best sessions we've had over
in scrutiny since since May um I think
the fact that the
people were respectful in the way
questions were asked and the way they
were answered we seemed to get a more
positive
response and uh you know they didn't
have a easy ride I'm not saying they did
um but I think it helped in engender a
more positive response
and they did say the consultation would
be um using the Gunning principles I
think is the right name I near he said
gning and I think that might be the
wrong wrong one uh the Gunning principle
so again I think that's that was a real
win um so I think a really good meeting
and thank you for the officers U Mr
Allison and Mr Perks who kept us uh kept
us going and one meeting to one
suggestion to make meetings go longer I
found that given out bars of chocolate
dairy milk well there are other
chocolate brands of valueable bars of
chocolate to to the members kept them
focused for some reason their
contribution lasted long so so perhaps
if you want to make the cabinet meetings
the chair of over scrutiny was Keen to
have some chocolate as well
so thank you very much thank you very
much indeed for your your contribution
uh I I would be particularly um I will
look forward to seeing the report the
minutes particularly of the um part of
the meeting that you had with the ICB in
particular I I think that would um that
that's at the heart of what we we should
be doing as an overview and scrutiny
committee is looking at at overview and
scrutiny of not only what goes on in
this Council but also the the partners
that you know working with not against
but working with and trying to U
understand and find out more about the
the rational and uh and I look forward
to that report really do look forward to
that report so thank you very much
indeed for that councelor
passingham I'd just like to add that
especially as I'm a counselor for
shipston uh that one thing I gained from
it was the fact that the ICB um reminded
us that if um if the ICB after the
public
consultation decided that there should
be beds at the Elena hospital or that
there should be more beds in other uh
hospitals
well there should be any bz at shipston
um and they commissioned them off Swift
that Swift would have to provide them so
we need to remember that the overall
decision body is the ICB and not
Swift council cter do you want to come
in on this item yes I think it was it
was a very useful um I think debate on
Friday because we had the discussion
about sill and we had a discussion with
the ICB and clearly this Council has
given a very substantial amount of money
through the sill fund to shipston and
that money still hasn't been spent and I
think one of the things that I was
worried about from from that meeting was
we didn't really get a commitment about
Beds which I know is um very very dear
to the heart of people in in shipland
District um going forward one of the
reasons why obviously we've we've pulled
the current report is once again we're
proposing potentially that to give
another very large amount of money to um
to our to to the NHS in in relation to
Stratford hospital um and I think we
need to be very careful about how we how
we uh ensure that that money is going to
be spent and not just going to sit in
the NHS funds um and not have Clarity
for that so that's all going to be part
of the review that we're going to do
over the next month till we bring the
next report to you thank you very much
indeed thank you much very much for your
uh your your report on the OV and
scrutiny committee Part D is the cabinet
committees we have no cabinet committees
uh part e is on block items uh and
unless anybody uh has any any questions
um that they wanted to raise and nobody
did raise them with me at the start of
the meeting they are approved on block
uh so items 11 is the cabinet work
program item 12 the climate change panel
and then item uh so those they that they
are taken on
block all everybody's happy with that
because it's um you know it's just an
nonblock item and then Part F is other
matters urgent business I've not been
notified of any urgent business so with
that I believe that this meeting is
finished